hey guys welcome back to another video
and today's gonna be a little bit of a
different one like I said last week or
in my last video that is that the devs
are on Christmas leave so there isn't
going to be a dev stream this week that
I don't know when this videos gonna be
up whether it'll be Thursday or Friday
but hopefully they'll hopefully be
coming back I believe next week they
said so everything will go back to its
regular scheduled programming on next
Thursday we'll get right back to those
devastated caps but for today's video I
took a clip from the stream that we did
a couple days ago on Saturday and I
played an eight-man conk match with the
subs a lot of you guys seem to enjoy
this match it was a lot of fun seeing as
most of us don't really know how to play
conquer a lot so it was really fun
experience obviously as you guys know I
do a lot of news type stuff for for
honor and definitely nothing toward the
gameplay a lot of the other youtubers
deal with that that's why I don't really
go into that type of field especially
because I'm not really good at the game
myself so I kind of try to stick away
from that well I decided to switch
things up for this type of video and
especially because a lot of you
requested that I do put this into a
video
but either way guys if you do enjoyed
this video be sure to give it a like
subscribe if you're new forfor honor I
always do the news the leaks and
discussions of for honor hit the bar and
exit so you never miss an upload of mine
my two most recent videos will be on
screen at the end of the video if you do
want to check those out with that guys
hope you have a great rest of your day I
hope you enjoy the video peace out
[Music]
you captured zone hey you lost sown see
so much fun all right
or should we do oh my god that almost
killed me I didn't notice that yo what
you thinking Hamza oh you're gonna
[ __ ] prick
all right I got you
I'm being chased there's a big-ass fight
over here and I'm missing out our poor
teammate captaincy
damn
Hamza did kill me
you lost sold us we got word
I've got your loss I can't wait to keep
area
oh dude he has no idea oh no they're all
coming no do this for of oh my god who's
here with me get killed
I've no clue what I'm doing I'm just I'm
just shoulder bashing and hitting
heavies in hopes that something will
work right now no back off I couldn't
save my teammate again oh [ __ ] I didn't
mean that I'm gonna do so they're bad
[Music]
oh no oh no oh what is my body my body's
in the wall yeah I appreciate the rebuy
oh [ __ ] well [ __ ] I don't know how this
is gonna go but it's not going to end
well
oh good hit oh my goodness that zone is
incredible
captures oh hey
you know he has no idea of coming for me
I missed that have been crazy I was at
it he's still here oh my god is just
continuously getting smacked Barney you
poor guy I'll rip red thing probably
disconnected so go pick him up after
this no problem
I'm being chased by two more comics I
see that on the map
you capture Jesus I cannot hit anything
I'm just missing I mean everyone's
caring means show them the up right now
all the punch through right that's a
feat it's all good stone we'll come pick
you up after the game I mean come on
it's for honor it's never a for honor
game unless someone gets disconnected
that's just how it is
you capture zone'
didn't work what really I hit the wall
of all things I know if I'm gonna fall
yeah mmm I saw him on the lever and I
was like no I can disconnect one of my
favorite with one of my favorite
youtubers have to be in it
it's unfortunate did it happens it's all
good though ain't gonna leave you out
after this match after this amazing conk
match which sucks cuz I know you play
conch like a lot and it's just that's so
unfortunate who next though who should
we do next I'll ask it after just think
ask it after the stream and you're after
the street after the match anyway cuz I
don't like how people aren't in our in
the stream watching we're just kind of
playing I'll ask it after and we'll
figure out who we should play next
ooh look at oh look he's in the net Oh
oh my God where does his leg what took
[ __ ] his his whole leg went up his ass
Perry follow that right back you
captured so Georgie I'm getting killed
I mean yeah okay Oh God he launched off
the map ooh see that his body just
disappeared
so I gotta go bye Christine I see man
thanks for stopping by I'm gonna cap
this we can win this game I don't know
what this buff does
oh you scum I was too busy looking at
chat god damn it
a good fighter
oh and house key is getting shoulder bag
oh these these out of nowhere shoulder
bashes that just knock you on your ass
or probably the best thing about this
whole fight no good parry
I can't tell who's name that keeps
there's our bot POTUS all the way if the
other objective
new capture zone a you've lost enemy
party
okay I have full faith in this one by
one be for it well it's going through
the vibe dude he's so cocky oh it's over
oh no it's it's over
you gotta start throwing revenge out bro
there you go BAM that why is this so
entertaining to watch
oh did you
did you boys that bought was going
pretty he was going pretty damn well he
was doing he's doing fairly well